-Hey, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This week we've been turning
the top of our show over t
"Late Night" writer
Amber Ruffin.
Every evening,
she has told us stories
of her encounters
with the police.
Here once again is Amber.
-The last two days,
I've told stories about
my run-ins with the cops.
Today I'm going to tell yo
a story about
a run-in with the cops.
Okay, I was living in Chicago,
and my friend Anthony
had just left my house.
Now, he goes out the door,
across the porch,
down the stairs, gets on
his bike and rides away.
I shut the door, I go inside
I change into my pajamas.
And when I come out of my room
I see that
he has left his wallet.
So I call him.
He comes back to get it.
I step out onto the porch with
no shoes, in my pajamas.
And instead of walking to
the end of the porch
and down the stairs, I jus
reach over the side of the porch
to give him his wallet back.
So, he rides up on his bicycle
and just lets his bicycle fall
and then reaches up
to get his wallet.
Now, at that moment,
I'm reaching down
and he's reaching up, a cop ca
pulls up, flashes its lights
The cop gets out, and she'
like, "Hold it right there
We gotcha!"
I'm like, "Okay."
Now, everything she says to us
she says with her hand
on her gun.
Now, I'm terrified,
because while I'm a black lady
Anthony is a black man,
and this cop is a tiny,
little white lady.
Now, I'm scared.
Anthony's scared.
I've had a lot of run-ins
with the cops at this point.
And isn't it hilarious tha
when people say
"run-ins with the cops,"
they mean they got caught
doing something?
But when I say it, I just mean
being a person that they bother?
Okay, so, this cop says,
"Why were you guys
running from the police?"
And we're like, "We're not
I'm not running anywhere.
I live here."
And she's like, "Okay."
Meanwhile, I'm like,
bitch, I have no shoes on.
I don't say that.
I say, "I'm in my pajamas
with no shoes on,"
and she goes,
"Let me see both your I.D.'s."
I go, "Okay, but to get my I.D.,
I have to go
in the house, okay?"
And she's like, "Fine."
So I go in the house, and
the whole time I'm in the house,
she's asking Anthony
a million questions.
So, I come up.
I give her my I.D.
She says,
"This address is from Nebraska."
And she's right.
I go, "Oh, yeah, I don't hav
a new Chicago I.D. yet."
And she goes, "Well, then I need
proof you live here.
Go get some mail."
Now, this is where the story
takes a turn,
and I can't describe it exactl
except to say
now she has unsnapped that thing
that holds your gun in place
and is holding on
to her gun tighter.
So, I go inside
and I'm freaking out
because she's going to shoot
my friend Anthony
for just being bigger than her
So I go in,
and I tear up the house,
looking for a piece of mai
with my name on it,
but I just moved there,
so I don't really have any
So, I go, I get the mail,
I come out,
and for some reason,
she has calmed down.
I give her the mail.
She looks at the mail, and she
looks at us and she goes,
"Okay, from now on, when I tel
you to stop, you stop."
Now, remember, she's never
told us to stop anything.
And I look at Anthony like
"Oh, my God, are you going t
handle this cop lying on us?
And he looks at me and he look
at the cop and he goes, "Okay.
I look at him and I go, "Okay,
and we live to get harasse
another day!
Because that's the kind of thing
you have to do
to stay alive when you're black.
You have to let the police
lie to you at your own house
That's it. That's my story
We used to open this show
with fun jokes,
but for the last three days,
we've opened this show
with stories about me
getting mistreated by the cops
And if you're tired of hearing
these stories, do something!